les faits se sont sans aucun doute
penchées sur le berceau du dernier né
des hélicoptères de l'aérospatiale la
s350 5 dont vous voyez ici le prototype
en vol au-dessus de la région de marine
avant même d'être mis en fabrication
laisse 355 aussi baptisé twinstar été
commandé à 100 exemplaires dérivés de
l'écureuil
un hélicoptère léger monoturbine de 5 6
places déjà vendues à 4 160 exemplaires
le twin star est un bi turbine léger de
même capacité qui emprunte à son aîné le
maximum d'éléments mais grâce à ses deux
turbines de 425 chevaux chacune au lieu
des 650 chevaux de l'unique turbines de
l'écureuil et à une plus grande capacité
en carburant
le twin star va plus vite plus loin et
surtout avec une plus grande sécurité
puisqu'il peut voler sur un seul moteur
c'est surtout cette dernière
caractéristique que souhaitaient les
clients américains de l'écureuil dont
beaucoup utilisent l'appareil pour
travailler au dessus de la mer notamment
pour la recherche et l'exploitation
pétrolière
après le succès initial tu 350 écureuils
qui avait été dessinée pour le marché
civil
nous avons constaté une très forte
demande de la part des utilisateurs pour
le même appareil mais avec deux moteurs
quelle est la place de l'aérospatiale
aux états unis depuis beaucoup d'années
maintenant nous sommes intéressés aux
marchés nord américains ont marché civil
parce que c'est la moitié au moins du
marché mondial et il y a quatre ans nous
avons créé une filiale à grand prairie
près de dallas chargée de commercialiser
et de supporter nos appareils sur le
continent nord américain
et aujourd'hui cette filiale couvrent à
peu près 20% du var la totalité du
marché civil américain ce qui est tout
de même extrêmement hélicoptère de
travail aérien ou de liaison le twin
stars dont le prototype a volé pour la
première fois le 28 septembre dernier 15
mois seulement après le début son étude
sera livré en série à la fin 2009 180
actuellement 191 exemplaires sont
commandés dont la plupart aux états unis
ce qui veut dire que le carnet est
rempli jusqu'à la fin de 1990